well experts have touted the health
benefits of hugging for years to lower
stress and even boost self-confidence
but just how long is the perfect hug as
tina cross reports researchers believe
they've cracked the code
embracing those we love in the midst of
a pandemic has never felt better
vel and frederick are newly engaged how
would you rate frederick's hugs 10 10.
researchers in london studied the
science behind the most satisfying
squeeze
the very short hugs the one second hooks
they were perceived as less pleasant to
better reveal the sensations behind
touch psychologists at goldsmiths
university of london blindfolded 48
women willing to be hugged by a stranger
one second hug a five second hook and a
ten second hope the ten second snuggle
was rated most pleasurable which was
surprising to us because we thought 10
seconds is so long surely
this at some point people might find it
less pleasant
in a second experiment researchers
watched nearly 200 people hug in social
settings something that could prove
challenging in the uk this is london
we're not very good at the touchy-feely
stuff
psychologists found crisscross hugs are
more common than the neck waist arm
position and gender also made a
difference men are more likely to use
the kind of crisscross arms
with other men
than women are among each other the
style of embrace didn't seem to affect
how enjoyable it was but the longer the
hug the better which surprised some
brits can only imagine 10 seconds if
it's like some sort of drunken hug
whatever the reason embracing hugs at a
time when they've been in such short
supply sure can't hurt tina krause cbs
news london